if you were to play a song as evidence
do you think that would be kind of weak
evidence yeah it's supposed to be though
it should be correct evidence like I
killed that mother and played in court
uh exhibit a I killed that mother uh I
rested my
[Laughter]
[Music]
case so did you guys hear that the Tupac
Shakur murder finally has a suspect
really who who is now in custody I heard
about why does the police work so slow
dude that's a good question so Tupac
those of you who don't know he died 1996
from a driveby shooting in Las Vegas
yeah he was leaving a Mike Tyson match
at the MGM on S on the 7th of September
when an unknown assent pulls up besides
him he opens fire he's inside a vehicle
with a red light he shot multiple times
including once in the chest which was
the lethal shot Su Knight the boss of of
Death Row Records which a lot of people
conspired that he was the one who
orchestrated they thought he was the
trigger man or at least the guy behind
it why because like Tupac trying to get
out of a deal he didn't want him out of
a deal or something some regular sh nice
[__] yeah we don't know we don't know
but there's a lot of theories a lot of
theories but he was also in the car at
the time so like that puts him at the at
the scene you we want to ask all those
guys a lot of questions right so um
Tupac was rushed to the hospital
pronounced dead 6 days later wow and now
they have arrested a man named Dwayne
Cafe D Davis as of the 29th of September
so you're probably watch this in like
February of
2027 when they found Tupac still alive
yeah um but although the exact charge or
charges are not immed are not
immediately clear we're not saying he
murdered him or anything like that but
there's just a suspect he's he's the
chief suspect right now arrested in
connection with the murder of Tupac um
and this has been one of those things
where just about every gang banger who
is like 80 years old and dying is like I
killed Tupac on their deathbed it's been
like that for like a decade at least so
finally maybe perhaps some clarity
involving the police cuz those guys
always say a bunch of [__] and the
police never even knock on the door cuz
maybe they can't connect them to the
crime at all like a lot of Wahoo
[__] people come out of the closet
about all kinds of murders saying like
oh I killed Kennedy they just want to be
famous hello my name is Richard I killed
Kennedy I'm jerking off right now in the
bathtub okay thank you was it like JayZ
and somebody else or I don't remember
who but they were the ones that were
going to court to make it so that you
couldn't use rap lyrics as evidence in
in a crime I thought there's been a lot
of that here say yeah I thought that was
a YSL guy or somebody or JayZ there
there's been a lot of that cuz people
you know in rap music they admit to
crimes a lot and that's that's not fair
that's not fair cuz how are these beats
going to be hard how are these tracks
going to be hard if they don't admit to
their [__] crime for the art you know
it's worth the death I think remember
Bobby Schmurda didn't they end up making
it it wasn't that you couldn't use them
but you can't use them as the prime
source of evidence like it's not
that's not the evidence but you can
listen to the song and follow clues that
the song provides in order to find the
other evidence if you were to play a
song as evidence do you think that would
be kind of weak evidence yeah it's
supposed to be though it should be
correct evidence like I killed that
[__] and played in court uh
exhibit a I killed that [__] uh
I arested my
case I just feel like it makes a lot of
sense but then but then the difference
was that they said it's not fair because
if Johnny Cash had a song about how he
killed someone they don't look into it
well you also have the right to not
incriminate yourself like through speech
in America so yeah it's just a different
but the difference he Sho someone you
know just to watch him die exactly but
the difference is that for for a lot of
the rap LS they were finding that they
were true it was like specific huh they
they Nam like streets and [__] some of
the drill [__] they were like uh buty
you did it I love that and then like you
got the rapper on like a bet video he's
like my shit's really real yeah yeah I'm
talking about real stories from the
streets I live that life but that's
that's the part that's unfair is that
like uh you you'd be messing with that
person's music career because what if
their career image is that they are
telling the truth so you're forcing them
to out their own career incriminate
themselves not incriminate themselves
for murder incriminate themselves for
not being hoard in their tracks yeah
yeah because if they're like no I didn't
do it I didn't that's not the guy that I
killed I killed somebody though and
they're like well are you willing killed
someone else but it's to it's specific
like I killed that guy and I put his
body in that Central Park in the corner
of that Big Cedar Tree under that one
swing not the one that's shaped like a
dinosaur but the other swing for the
children here's a longitude and latitude
it's like a Chappelle Show sketch I put
one arm under the slide and then the
other one under the monkey bars and then
you actually find the evidence specific
that's different that's different that's
here yeah you can't use that though in
2018 following a cancer diagnosis Mr
Davis said during an interview for bet
if you guys probably remember this a
little little touches of this right he
said he was one of the people in the
backseat of the Cadillac from which the
shots were fired also implicating his
nephew Orlando baby Lane Anderson he's
[__] riding out his own family
members well we'll see cuz Anderson
immediately denies any involvement in he
also died two years later in a shooting
himself in C that's the one Orlando did
when I was when I was talking to my I
have like a friend who like is obsessed
with this whole thing ever since
happened and like I was like yo did you
see like they got this dude in custody
he's like man it was that dude's cousin
like forever ago like they're not most
people that follow us are not impressed
by this news they're just like shut up
cuz they think the cousin did it I guess
they they've known who did it like in
the community for a really long Timey so
they're just like so they think it was
the guy who just died baby L the guy who
died shortly after the real shooting or
the shooting happened I guess they got
they got him back for it already and it
was just like it was like Street you're
saying it was it was soon after it was
soon after according to him I everyone
has different theories but I guess like
you know got him back but in the streets
they think of the other guy and they
already served them Justice that's what
my friend's saying he's like he's like
nobody cares do they need like absolute
Street Justice though they're like you
was in the car [__] I guess like
they're like he was saying that whoever
shot Tupac ended up getting shot for
some other [__] cuz there's a lot of
reasons for them to shoot each other I
guess yeah but yeah he was in the car
[__] who are you Frank Lucas
over here you're from the streets and I
can't incriminate myself on this video I
thought Tupac faked his death and he's
hanging out in Costa Rica that's what I
keep hearing is it in Argentina no
that's Hitler that's H that's your guy
Hitler that's your bud your guy that's
your F dude the F you're mine fur as you
say off camera yo who knows you seen
hunting Hitler though no it's a really
good dock yeah cuz they all fled to
Argentina well and can there's so much
evidence of Nazis in in Argentina I love
how every couple of months we cycle like
stories it's a fascinating story though
it is though because we've already Deja
vued this because right after he said
that I went home and I watched the first
episode isn't it good are you going to
do the same thing and then we talked
about this too yeah and it is we talked
about that talk no we did no YouTube
History Channel right no History Channel
which is on Disney
oh okay okay I cancel Disney really but
where do you think Tupac is huh Costa
Rica I think he's dead they think he's
in s Chili's well I heard that he faked
his own death so he can hide from the
feder rales and Suge Knight so from the
Mexican police and Suge
Knight I think that makes more sense of
anything I've heard what about biggy
what about biggy what happen to him oh
he's dead biggy dead did they catch
biggy big dead he's been dead didn't you
see him carrying that big extra large
coffin it was huge oh that that's the
evidence right there hug cuz he's big
dude I saw some I was watching some old
freestyle videos of uh uh biggie M when
he was a young lad he was 18 freestyling
block when he's shaking the [__] out of
that Fried Chicken bag bro he's he's
like [__] He's shaking and bacon no
he has a watch his video he's like
rapping on the street right and then he
has a bag of food and there's like
grease at the back and he's shaking it
so hard you see this brown paper bag
just being shaken while he's rapping do
you think it's sh and bake oh it was
popular at the time very popular in the
'90s it was by the way he popularized it
I'm guessing he could be I don't know
it's a sick video though so dope but you
know what what the sad thing is as an
adult looking back at the whole Tupac
Biggie [__] I feel like biggie was
bullied hardcore hardcore into this
whole [__] why would you be bullied
bullied for what well I think Su Knight
conspired all of this [__] and told
Tupac you know they were friends yeah
like they they stayed together all that
stuff right and then um when Tupac got
shot at you know he survived those shots
at the music studio he
blamed P Diddy Biggy and all those guys
for doing that and they're like we
didn't do that but that's what started
all I see yeah and I and I and I don't
see those guys as like those gangster
guys I just see them as like you know
musicians what of all the things you
could believe big4 what do you think
they were bullying him about they
weren't calling him big and fat they
were oh they were on hit him up he says
that's why I [__] your [__] you fat
[__] Okay that's the first thing
he said that blows my mind I had no idea
I wouldn't have guessed that I never
would have guessed that if you gave me
100 guesses Jimmy Butler is not even fat
I don't even know wait Jimmy Buffett
just died Jimmy Buffett
don't make me an [__] come on but he
didn't make fun of them for being fat
but what they did do is accuse them of
oh you attacked us and all that they
created this whole War to sell records
all that [__] whether Tupac believed it
or not yeah I was into it yeah did they
talk about his mama at all no I don't
think you're allowed to yeah you're not
it's on the streets right Tupac does go
I'm sorry Mama that's Eminem if you do
you need Wilmer valderama around why
he's the referee he's the only one that
can make sense of all of it
oh yeah I got to say though s why I
[__] your [__] you fat [__]
is one of the most badass lines in the
history you know why he said that okay
so during the whole drama Faith Evans
she was the singer that was dating
biggie at the time and then she was huh
she's dope she's really good she's
really good and then during the whole
drama she was like well I'm friends with
Pac too so let me just go over there and
try to simmer all this [__] down so
they have a picture together of Pac and
Faith Evans and then later uh Pac
dangles it in front of Biggy like yo
that's why [__] your [__] you fat
[__] do you think he really did
it I don't I don't know I don't think
but yeah please tell me no those are the
stories
of I don't think he did but I that that
was the whole drama is like it's like he
used that as a chess piece got it let us
know in the comments do you think Tupac
[__] fith Evans please say that's
really good but I know who he did [__]
it's Jada pink and Smith and Jada pink
and Smith always Compares uh Will Smith
to Tupac cuz Jada and Tupac were madly
in love all this stuff and she's always
like no one's ever going to man up to
the man that Tupac was and she says that
today huh yeah but will was fine with it
ah no one's fine with that oh oh Jesus I
love '90s
[Music]
drama